within your fingertips are many sensors
feeding you information on the tactile
world grip friction pressure all these
things you need to pick up a pen or feel
bumps on a piece of paper now
researchers have created a synthetic
system that captures many aspects of
this biological feat this neuromorphic
system uses flexible electronics to
sense and report on tactile information
classical computers get along by
crunching large amounts of ones and
zeros which can add up to a lot of
energy consumption we can't have our
brains getting hot like an overworked
laptop so our bodies have a super
efficient way of dealing with a barrage
of input for example when there is
pressure on many sensors on the skin
those signals are funneled to a single
neuron and if it reaches a certain
threshold that triggers a response that
passes the message on signals from these
neurons converge on the next layer up
which integrates the information further
with other sources here's how the
artificial neuron replicates biology
touching the pressure sensor increases
the electrical voltage between a pair of
electrodes and sensors that extra
voltage is used by a neighboring device
called a ring oscillator to create a
string of electrical pulses those pulses
and ones from neighboring ring
oscillators are then sent to a third
device called a synaptic transistor
which integrates the incoming signals
and generates its own series of pulses
depending on the pattern it receives for
example applying steady soft pressure
produces a series of pulses at a
different rate than applying more
forceful pressure researchers showed
that they could use their neuromorphic
sensors to detect the placement and
motion of a small rod across the surface
and detect a Braille pattern they even
sent the output electrical impulses to
an electrode inserted in the
attached leg of a cockroach and showed
that the insects nervous system could
receive the pulses and move the leg in
response
none of these parts are particularly new
but using them to generate responses to
tactile information is in the future
cheap and efficient systems like these
could create large arrays of sensors for
prosthetics and these types of circuits
can aid in building robots that can
sense and respond to the environment
it's fine to have a pre-programmed bot
build a car but what it needs to respond
to changes in the world around it
including moving people the more senses
the better
[Music]
[Music]